- [Mark] Okay, so Mackenzie and Marcus.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You guys are, you're
from England originally, right?
- I'm born and bred in London, Hampstead.
- And I'm from Leicester,
which is in the Midlands.
- [Mark] Did you guys know each
other there or you met here?
- No, we met in, I was running strip clubs
in the West End and
- In London.
- I guess you came in as a dancer
and that's kinda how we
originally met actually.
- And then I offered him many, three ways
to come home with me and
it eventually worked.
Pretty much.
So it's true, right.
- Well you know two is better than one.
(Marcus laughs)
- [Mark] So let's go
back to your childhood.
You guys grew up in what kind of families?
- My family was very, my dad
was a licensee, a publican,
and my granddad I would say his dad
was also publican in the same pub.
So he grew up running that business.
And then actually, I
actually kind of worked
with him in that for 10 years.
Very normal business, like blue
what they call white collar,
blue collar, which is it?
You know, like kind of
the middle of the road
kinda people.
- [Mark] Yeah, solid family.
- Yeah, solid.
- In the country
family.
- Not religious,
couple of businesses in one
part, one part in London,
one part in Norwich.
Just very, very normal, honestly.
As normal as you can get.
- He's the black sheep.
- [Mark] He's also the black sheep?
- Well yeah obviously
- Black sheep.
- I did porn you know, but you know
it was never judged,
it was never an issue.
It felt like I worked in
a bank, no one gave me any
and still to this day,
everything is amazing.
Honestly.
- [Mark] That's great.
- So yeah, I've been very lucky.
- So me, on the other hand,
I come from, I have five sisters.
It's a whole lot of girls.
From my mom and dad, I'm the
youngest of the first batch,
which is how I like to put it.
- First batch.
- So my mom and dad got divorced
when I was five years old.
So technically I think
my dad kind of raised me
but he had three jobs, so
he was never really home.
So therefore it was kind
of left up to my sisters.
So, there's me and then my older sister's
like nine years older than me.
And then the other one, is
like 10 years older than me.
So I guess we were kind of kind of left
to fend for ourselves a little bit.
My dad works in hospitals.
He builds hospitals, very normal family.
My mom is, I guess, a
housewife she's remarried
and and whatnot, which is how
I've got three more sisters.
(Marcus laughs)
- [Mark] So fairly normal childhood.
- Yeah no real, nothing
off key, like crazy.
Like, Oh my God, nothing
tragic happened to make me
be like some porn star or whatever.
And then be like, Oh my God I'm gonna go
into porn or whatever.
- [Mark] So you were
working in a strip club
and you were managing it.
- Yep.
- [Mark] And.
- And we met there, I was
with someone at the point
I'd been with this girl for probably
nearly 11 years or more all ready.
- That makes me sound really bad.
- And she just seduced, what?
You seduced me whatever.
- Oh, whatever.
- You're the ones
offers a threesomes.
And yeah, eventually, basically
I started realizing that
that relation I was in wasn't really,
it was just I was stuck in a rut
with someone was great
but it just wasn't for me,
she was more exciting obviously.
And we just ended up getting together
- And ironically, then I
met your ex-girlfriend.
- Yes.
- And we were all friends.
- Well it seems to be
quite the thing these days.
- So we're all friends.
So, you know, so we got together.
We were, stripping for a good while.
I think this is back in like 2000 right?
- Yeah I think it's 2000.
- I think I started my
porn career in 2002.
Two, maybe yeah, cause I basically
the business I worked for a company
called For Your Eyes Only
which was quite a big chain in the UK.
Spearmint Rhino decided to
come onto the map in England
and really decimated the business.
You know, they did a
lot of things that were
not done so to speak and of
course it affected our industry
You know, our business itself.
And I got just very
despondent with my company.
They weren't really
aggressive and making it work
and the business started
to fail a little bit.
It wasn't as good as it was.
And I said, you know what I'd been doing,
I'd done some porn,
I'd worked with some big companies.
And I was like, you know what?
I can make you the biggest porn star ever.
You got the look, you got the attitude.
As long as you listen to what
I tell you, you'll be amazing.
And literally contracts
started happening and working.
She was getting probably the
most money any girl was paid
in England.
- I didn't know
what to do with it.
For scenes, and when we
come to the AVN, you know
Jenna liked her and that was it.
Everyone liked her.
- [Mark] So that opened up the
doors in the United States.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Well I guess like I,
so what happened was
I was contracted to Playboy TV.
And Playboy TV wanted to send me out here
to do Showtime.
- Night Calls.
Night Calls on?
- No, to do Showtime for like
it was like for the AVN.
So they wanted me to like
host backstage for Showtime.
So, which is, which is
what opened the door
to the whole AVN experience for me.
And that's when I saw Jenna,
and I guess she liked what she saw her.
And then she offered my then agent
Mark Spiegler, a contract.
And then Wicked Pictures offered
them one at the same time.
So it's kinda like, who do you go to?
What do you do?
I wasn't even sure what a
contract was at the time
to tell you the truth so,
we would just kinda wing it in line huh?
- Well, it was just, you know
the contract meant you
wouldn't work every day.
You would probably shoot
maybe eight movies a year.
You'd do a bunch of photo shoots,
which was great promotion.
And you would have that title as, you know
Club Jenna contract star or
Wicked Pictures contract star.
Which was a big deal back then.
contract goes with the rate.
Hence Jessica James was
Hustler's contract star.
You know, it was a big thing
and it really pushed you.
- Yeah.
- To the top.
And then I got AVN best
new starlet of 2006
which was then just where
it just kind of took off.
From there.
- [Mark] And the industry has changed
a lot since then right?
- Immensely it's unrecognizable honestly.
And she's just come back in recently
so she's like wow.
- I mean, I've been
in and out, so I see the
changes as in it's massive
like now everybody's
shooting their own content.
So you're technically your own.
You're really your own boss.
- Brand as well.
- These days.
- And everything.
- [Mark] Is the
professionalism gone down or?
- Honestly, to a point, yes.
And the reason it's gone
down and I don't mean that
in a respect of how you
approach your job as a whole
but because these girls
now can make so much money
from their mobile phone,
the odds of them showing up
to a set or canceling a set
or just not giving a shit is big now.
Because they're making 10 or
20 grand a month on a phone.
They don't need the $1,000 scene.
So they'll just cancel.
Yeah, I'm not coming.
Whereas before that would never happen
you'd be blacklisted.
You're not going, you're done.
You know what I mean?
So I think it's great
for the performers us,
because we are able to
create our own content,
make a lot of money without having to
wait for a scene to happen
but it's gonna hurt the companies.
And it hurts people to produce content
because the people just
don't care as much.
- [Mark] So,
what are the upsides and
downsides of being a porn actor?
You guys were a couple
but you're no longer,
- Yes, yup.
- [Mark] But you're still friends.
- Yup.
- [Mark] Obviously.
- Yeah, that took a while.
We didn't speak for a long, long time.
Not really because of anything other than
than she was with someone.
and she wasn't allowed.
- That wasn't because of
like, that wasn't because
of us, in general,
that was because of outside parties.
- Yeah.
- We'll just leave it at that.
- [Mark] Yeah, we don't
need all those details.
But there must be an upside and downside
to being in a relationship
as a porn actor.
- It's difficult. like
we work together and like
he's very a free spirit
when it comes to his job.
Like, you know, I see it
very like, okay, money-wise
business-wise when we
first got in together
he was having his cake and
eating it too trust me.
- We're all like that we're men.
- Like, he was all like okay so.
I remember even with
that scene with Jessica
I was like, is this like, whatever?
And then he's all like, Oh, I don't know.
(Marcus laughs)
Let me just check her out on Twitter.
All right, babe.
(Marcus laughs)
You know, that kind of thing.
Mark's a free spirit when
it comes to his love,
let's put it like that.
- With a lot to go around.
(Marcus laughs)
I'm definitely more business
as in like,
- Yeah.
Oh, okay, I'm gonna go here,
I'm gonna do that,
I'm gonna, this is how
much I'm getting paid,
Mark's like in it for a good time too.
- Well, you know, I
have that emphasis where
if you're gonna do something
then you've gotta love it,
and to love it, I mean,
you have to really love it
with or without the money.
The money is definitely a bonus.
Don't get me wrong.
It's a bonus and it's the reason I do it,
but I wouldn't wanna do it
unless I really enjoyed it.
I just would, I'm not
gonna force myself to
do something that
doesn't feel right to me.
So I just, I guess my, I my trick my mind
into really enjoying it to the point where
maybe I get a little bit.
- Really enjoyed it.
Over zealous, over the top
and that can affect relationships
dramatically as she said.
- Yeah, because then
we're like, what the fuck?
Like what's he doing?
Like, you know, so he's
all over her social media
and it's like everyone's babe and baby,
like and you're like,
no, let's step it down.
(Marcus laughs)
- [Mark] Can you guys even
get involved romantically
with somebody outside the industry
or is that just isn't a possibility?
- It works occasionally I
got friends that, you know
I have a friend that's
was a big porn star,
was married to a female bank manager
and they have kids and it works great.
But on the other side
it doesn't work as well.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- It really depends on the
individuals unfortunately.
- I have been with
somebody that's not been
in the business and it is more difficult.
But they have their own fetishes going on.
And sometimes it's kinda weird to them
what we're in the business so it's like,
you know, and then I've
been with somebody also
that I've completely gave it up for.
And I'm like, you know, never asked me to
just because I wanted to, because I felt
like I needed to be true to them
to give them all of me
if you know what I mean.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So, it definitely affects relationships,
this business.
- I think the biggest problem
with being a porn star.
And I think like you were
saying about, you know, the
the upsides and the downsides is,
as a woman or as a guy, you
may get with an individual
that maybe isn't in the business.
And then they see you in a certain way.
They are maybe mesmerized by the fact
that you are a porn star in
a female sense, for instance.
And they expect things
from you because of that,
instead of it's just like, I love you or
I wanna to be with you whatever,
they want you to do crazy stuff
because that's what you do on camera.
Which for anyone that's
trying to have a relationship
that's the last thing you ever wanna do.
You want to be way away
from that side of your life,
because that's your job,
that's your work life.
This you want normality.
And when that person
doesn't want normality
they want you to do all this crazy stuff
you feel like you're constantly at work.
So, that's difficult for the women
doesn't happen for the men so much,
but that is definitely something I've seen
cause massive problems
in relationships with
women that are with men
that aren't in the business.
- [Mackenzie] Well cause they think
that we're completely bonkers.
(Marcus laughs)
- [Mackenzie] Even like, some of like
some of their scenarios
which they come up with
are even crazier.
- [Marcus] Than the porn.
- [Mackenzie] Than the porn scenarios.
And I'm like, and then they're all like
well now you gonna say this
and then they're gonna say that,
and you're looking at him like I can't
preempt what somebody's gonna say to me
like, how do we know that?
Like, so it's a whole fancy
that they've made up in the head
but it's gone way too far.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Mackenzie] So that can be difficult.
- [Marcus] Yeah, so
relationships in this industry
if you're in the business,
it's very difficult.
And my best friend told me, and
I'm gonna tell you the same.
It's mild impossible to
find something that works.
Because, somewhere along
the line may, may like it
in the beginning, but jealousy
will come in very soon.
And then they're like, well,
you're having sex on camera.
I wanna fuck these people for fun
because you're doing it.
That's where it goes tits up.
- I think sometimes you have to like,
I mean what makes sense is to stay within
your own business 'cause that person knows
that, okay, this is work, and this is work
and like each of us know
what's expected of each other.
So when it's an outside influence
like somebody that really
doesn't have anything to
do with this business,
they've made all these crazy scenarios
in their brain of what this is like
when it's really not like that.
- I think that's why
Hollywood stars really go
with other actors because
they're involved in that world.
They know they're gonna be away
for three months during a movie, whatever.
And that's why people stick
to those little, those little
I guess that niche of this group of people
'cause they understand each other.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know.
- I mean, I used to tell him like
I'm doing an anal scene tomorrow.
He'd be like, all right cool.
Two Immodium, we'll get an enema,
you know, we're not eating
after six o'clock, you know
he already knows the drill so.
- But it's funny 'cause,
and I said this is a
cause mainstream people, normal civilians
have this attitude.
So, if I walked in and saw
my girlfriend getting fucked.
I'd be like, all right, do
you want anything to eat?
But if she's walking down the street
holding hands with someone.
- Oh no.
- I'd lose my fucking shit.
'Cause it's the flip that is normal.
But you having feelings
and holding someone's hand
and talking to that doesn't happen.
So we have the flip side of life.
Whereas most people would
go mad if they walked in
and saw their girlfriend having sex.
But if they hold hands they'd be like,
Oh, who's he?
You know it wouldn't be a big deal.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So we are the reverse of the
of the civilians if you will.
- I guess it's kinds strange huh?
- It just our world is
just flipped upside down.
It's like, you know.
- [Mark] And you guys have been
in the industry a long time.
You must have some
interesting stories, right?
- Yeah, a few.
- We have a.
- It depends, what kind of
stories you want?
- What kind of stories
do you want cause we have a lot.
- [Mark] Why don't you shock me?
Surprise me.
- I don't know.
- Well, we, there's depends.
I mean, there's the dirty ones.
- There's loads.
- The disgusting side of the business
I'll give you that for the first time.
So, picture this you're on a set.
Three guys, one girl, it's an anal scene.
Rough hardcore anal scene.
- This is not me by the way.
- European, this isn't her by the way.
- Just for the record.
- So,
the anal scene is going ahead,
probably in a position where it's causing
a lot of air buildup
in that area.
- Vacuum.
Guy's got a very big helmet,
pulls out, creates a suction
comes out, literally
pebbled out shit the walls,
all over the place, hits the
floor, girl starts crying.
Guy, sees it, throws up,
other guy slips in it falls
down making angel wings on
the shit and the fucking.
So you can imagine it's
kind of like a movie
just that you wouldn't
believe could ever happen.
- [Mark] Wow.
- But that's,
(Mark laughing)
- We have a lot.
- Just a, oh my God that
would happen but yeah
because you know, let's
face it doing an anal scene
is one thing, but you
don't really want anything
else to happen from that anal scene.
So when anything does
happen to that kind of level
it's not very pleasant.
So who knows?
You know.
- I mean, anything can happen.
Trust me
- It really is, it is.
- When you're gonna go in
there, anything could happen.
It's just the act of God that day.
You know, it's like,
you hope, you're hoping
your enema and your two Immodium
are really gonna save your ass.
- Save your ass.
- But,
I literally remember when
I shoved like two gallons
of milk up my butt, I shoved two gallons
I go a little far with my scene.
So, if someone gives me a role,
I get a bit excited about it.
I'm like, oh, I'm a maid today.
- I'm a maid.
- I'm no wild dude.
I'm no wild dude let's shove some milk
up my butt and let
Scott Nails fuck it out.
Sounds good.
- Yeah.
- So we go above and beyond.
- Not the best idea.
- I've shoved a phone
in my vagina and it rang
it was like the best service ever.
(Marcus laughs)
So I think, you know.
- She's pretty crazy I've got,
I'm totally not that person,
but that was, she was very hardcore.
I was very, I did the romantic movie.
She did the fucking
- Oh no.
- Insane movies.
- I've shoved snooker
balls up peoples butts.
- Oh yeah, when you lost that one.
- Oh yeah.
- In Lanzarote.
- That was in Portugal that was.
- No, Lanzarote.
- Oh, Lanzarote.
- [Mark] I read a few stories now
of like these really extreme
like they're pushing their limits.
- They really are
pushing them, even today.
- Well that was back then.
- Yeah, but today they're just,
because it's sex has become a circus.
How much you can do,
how much you can take.
You know, I loved the days,
honestly, I loved old porn.
I loved the Tom Barron days with the
beautiful girl walking
down a spiral staircase
and the guy's in the tux playing a piano
and this beautiful
music, it' shot on film.
That's what I like.
That's not what we sell
- That's not right.
- These days.
- But that's not.
- And that's why I'm not wanting
to be around much longer.
'Cause it's not, it's not
the world I came into.
- He likes the Fabio
world of like you know.
- Well maybe not the
little hair 'cause I can't.
- Yeah, the whole.
- You know what I mean?
I like the beauty side.
- I'm not like that, I'm
like, you challenge me,
give me a challenge,
let's go tell me I can't do it.
I'll do it one better let's go.
That's me.
(Mark laughs)
- Hence why we didn't stay together.
(Marcus laughs)
- He's romantical and I'm not.
- Yeah, very different
individuals actually.
- I don't wanna be like, ooh make out.
- I wouldn't wanna do it any other way.
I just don't wanna do it other ways.
It's just no point.
There's no feeling then
there's no point to it.
That's my opinion.
- I have a feeling, to
get fucked in the butt.
- Yeah but that's not.
(Marcus laughs)
See what I'm dealing with.
- Like, it's just like it's different.
Like just challenge me please.
Like, I guess it's like
the intensity I get.
- You're just well, you're an extremist.
You like extreme, like you're
the extreme sports fucker.
I'm the normal guy.
- I wanna see.
- You're the GoPro of sex.
I'm the Hasselblad.
I like just cool quality.
And you like mad and fast and crazy.
- I wanna see how much I can do.
I wanna be pushed to my limits that's it.
I just you know, if you
can make me cry, then it's.
- Oh God, see what I mean.
- [Mark] Well, I mean
to be in the industry,
you almost need that temper right?
- I think now, what I mean the industry's
changed so much it's so varied you know,
from the fetish side
of things to, you know
the kind of stuff she's talking about.
Anal doesn't seem to be as big
a deal as it was back then.
- No.
- I'll be honest with you.
- It's not.
- It's nowadays, unfortunately
it's very heavy into the incest.
I constantly work in
stepdad roles, which I
cannot stand.
- I'm also someone's mom.
- I hate it.
She always plays the MILF.
So now porn is designed around
niche words for, you know data tracking
and all that stuff to find
the porn you wanna watch.
And most of it is gonna be
step-daughter, daughter, MILF, son.
That's basically the most,
I mean, I look at my Pornhub numbers.
I have 280 million views on my Pornhub.
- [Mark] 280 million.
- 80, but I wondered
where's that coming from?
So I'm looking, you know,
at the things I watch,
I look at these gorgeous movies
that I've done with her,
I've done with Wicked Pictures,
195,000 views.
And then I look at, I cum
in my stepdaughter's pussy.
25 million views.
That's the state of the world now
it's the extreme stuff they wanna see.
The weird stuff, the
stuff that shouldn't be
the taboo stuff effectively.
Taboo.
- I'm very taboo.
- Very taboo.
I'm into gay guys.
- Ah, she's into all kinds of crazy stuff.
- This is, that's my thing.
So.
- [Mark] Something for everybody.
- Yeah.
- Definitely.
(Marcus laughs)
- Totally.
- Like he always gives me shit for it.
Don't you?
- I think because I think because I'm so
I call myself the vanilla
porn star, you know
they're like what's your thing?
I'm like having sex.
And they're like, what'd
you watch the then?
You know, I don't have a thing,
I like contact, eye contact.
Beautiful girl, nice surroundings,
lovely music, beautiful lighting.
Leave me and her together,
we're gonna make magic.
I'm not even gonna ask what she.
(Mark and Marcus laughing)
- My thing.
- Gonna go there.
- [Mark] What's your fantasy?
- What's your perfect scenario?
Then there we go.
- Wait am I in it or I'm not in it?
- Yeah, you're in it.
- Oh, like, cause I was like,
wait, am I watching it or?
- Well you watching it
and then you being in it.
- I don't know I had a dream,
I'll tell you about my
dream the other day.
I had a dream that I
was in a bisexual porn
where it was two guys are
at it with each other.
And I was just like this.
And I wasn't really sure what to do.
I was like, Oh I'm gonna go in there
and we're gonna go and then I woke up.
It wasn't, it was not sexual
but it was like kind of a test.
- Voyeur based, but what
would you do in a scene?
What would you want to happen
if you was to shoot a scene
now that would be exactly
what you wanna be involved in,
what would it be?
- I don't know.
- I always said that I'm gonna go out
on a massive transsexual gang bang
and I really think, I'm gonna do it.
I really think I'm going to do it.
Like, you know, cause like there are so
many beautiful transsexuals
out there like.
- There's so many beautiful
women out there though.
Isn't there?
Why go that route?
You know?
But again, that's what I'm saying
there is something for everyone.
- [Mark] You like to push the envelope?
- Envelope yeah.
- I think that's how I started my career.
I started my career on
my second scene, DP.
I'm gonna end it like.
- With a bang.
- With something crazy.
- Yeah that makes sense.
- I don't know
I might like it and stay in the who knows.
But that's definitely my thing.
I'm definitely on the more extreme
and like pushing the taboo.
Like only because people say girls like me
should not do that kind of thing.
Now I wanna push that
kinda envelope and be like,
no just because you look
a certain way or you
- Right.
- Or you act a certain way does not mean
that I'm not gonna be into these things
that you say are taboo.
What to me they're a normal Friday night.
(Marcus laughs)
You know, so.
- Oh my God it's funny 'cause I remmeber
when we used to shoot
together for Club Jenna,
people would literally run out the scene
because they, we, they just
waiting for the explosion.
'Cause we didn't gel very well
as a couple in a sex scene,
we were great as individuals
but together in scenes,
you know, she would be like going,
like I'm having sex with her from behind.
And she'd looked back at
me with disdain and go
is that all you fucking got?
And I'm like, I'll fucking
kidney punch you bitch.
And she's like, fucking do it.
- But Mark also
- And then I was like
let's leave.
The cameraman pointed the cameras there
and they walking out of the door.
This is one of the biggest
companies in the world.
They're like, oh, here they go again.
- Well, Mark always makes this noise too.
- Oh here we go.
- All right, in every single
sex scene that he does.
- Have you watched that in my latest one?
- I have to zone out.
(Marcus laughs)
- So like he goes like this.
(Mackenzie inhales)
It annoys the fuck out of me,
I'm like this he does it and then
it sends me into like it triggers me.
And I'm like, what are you doing?
Like, 'cause we had to
work together recently
and I'm like, Mark just
please try not to do it, like.
- Did I do it?
- Yes.
- Did I, when?
- But like now I'm
trying to really intently
get to you
- You're looking for it now,
you're looking for it.
I have been looking if for
it for the past 15 years.
- Right.
(Mackenzie inhales)
- Watch it, does it.
(Mark laughs)
- I've might have been on
a Slurpee how'd you know?
(Marcus inhales)
- He does it all the time.
- Drink.
- And it either makes me laugh
or it sends me into a
whirlwind of craziness.
So he goes,
(Mackenzie inhales)
I'm gonna guess each one of us has like a
- Yeah everyone has something
- go-to
thing.
- They do.
- That we do when we're
like not really thinking.
"Cause our brain just goes there
like I think mine is, Oh, it's so good.
- Well, you know that
the problem is with porn
and this is what I hate about it
is it's like we have been given a glossary
of words that we constantly use over
and over again, which I hate.
I'd rather gag the girl.
- What do you say?
- So she doesn't.
I don't say anything.
I whisper in a girl's ear.
I'm talking about what I'm doing.
See that the trick of dirty talk is
basically giving someone the play by play
of what you're going to
do, what you want to do.
And you're saying it in a certain way
to make it very sexual, very stimulating
to someone in the mind.
So that's what I do.
You know, whereas a lot of people,
they say all this false stuff.
I hate it when a girl goes,
fuck me with that big dick.
I'm like, have you seen, I
don't have a fucking big dick.
And I hate that, winds me
up when a girl says that,
I'm just like shut up
bitch it ain't fucking big.
- Well I decided a long.
(Marcus laughs)
- It's annoying, it's like, it's not real,
be real just say fuck me.
I like the fuck way you me
or I like the way you feel.
'Cause it's a porn thing.
'Cause it's all about big is good,
when but when you get on set with girls
and they say a bid dick
they're like, Oh shit.
- [Mark] Do you find the
outside world judges you guys?
Because if, once they find out
that you're in the industry?
- I'll be honest.
- It depends.
- I don't think we've had that problem.
- No because we're so blatantly out there
where they it's either you
like it or you don't so.
- [Mark] I spoke to one agent when he
says he goes on a cruise he
has to say that he works in
tech or something like that.
- Really.
- [Mark] Just to kill the
conversation from going,
Oh you work in porn.
- Funny I've never, if I've
ever said, and I've always said
I never lie about what I do.
And it's never been
nothing but positive ever.
Probably now especially
because I think this day
and age people are very
enamored by the fact that wow
I've never met anyone
or tell me more about,
Oh I've got so many questions.
Never had anyone go, eh.
Never had that once.
Maybe that's because I'm a guy,
you know because if a girl
said it to another female
maybe that would be shunned upon.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's
funny you guys different.
- I mean, I don't think I have many,
I have a few like close
female relationships
I don't have a ton of them because then
I've gotta explain myself to you.
Like explain like the things,
you know, and to me I can't
have a friendship with somebody
without them knowing all of me.
So like I'm not ashamed of my past.
Like I'm not ashamed of what I've done,
I'm not ashamed of what I still do.
It's just my life.
You know?
And I would like to, I don't know.
It's like, even though
I have two children too.
I'm gonna raise them to be very,
open-minded about a lot of things.
Even though we have definitely
not touched subject yet.
(Marcus laughs)
But.
- [Mark] How old are they?
They are 11 and 12.
I teach them that love is love.
And like, definitely with like, you know,
I guess one of my daughters
came home the other week
and said that there was a,
there's a boy in her class
that would like to be a little girl.
So I was like, oh, this is
happening earlier these days.
You know?
So we touched on various subjects
and definitely love is
love does not matter
what sex you are or you know
who identify as love is love.
And it's the same feeling,
whether you're a boy, boy
girl, girl, whatever.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So it's a, it's definitely
an interesting topic.
- I mean, the thing is
what I've noticed about
the porn world and what I derived
from being in porn is, people watch porn
for a lot of reasons.
Some of it's obviously
sexual gratification,
but honestly a lot of it
male as well as female
sometimes is they wanna learn.
Maybe they think they're
not doing something, right.
So they're trynna use porn
as kind of like a learning,
learning platform which unfortunately
is the wrong place to look.
It will give you some
pointers, but most of it
will be disinformation
because everyone thinks
well most men think you
gotta have a big dick.
- No.
- I've been around 16 years
and I have definitely am not
within the realms of
some of the guys I know.
And I make more women cum than they do.
Hands down no question.
It's been my specialty for years.
So it's not a problem if you're not big
but what is a problem is if you don't know
how to make a woman feel good
regardless of how you do it
whether it's your fingers, your mouth,
your hands, whatever.
If you don't know how to treat a woman
right in the bedroom and
outside of the bedroom,
doesn't matter what you're packing.
It's not gonna be any use to you.
And I, porn gives this terrible thing,
Oh you gotta throat fuck 'em for hours.
You gotta pound to the
pound, them to the ground.
And kids, these days are watching that.
And that's what they're
going out and doing.
And their girls are like,
what the fuck is going on?
And even girls that think that, you know
I'll pick up a girl.
For instance, if I was
gonna be with a girl
and she'll try and deep throat me,
I'm like what the fuck are you doing?
Is there a camera in this room?
What the hell?
There's no need for it, I don't like it.
It doesn't feel good.
- It's Friday night.
I doesn't feel good I don't like it.
I want blow jobs are supposed to be
sensual, slow and eye contact.
That's what they're supposed to be.
- And use your tongue.
- And use your tongue right.
But you know, porn is giving
this very bad perception
of what sex is supposed to be,
what you're supposed to be,
which it isn't supposed to be.
- That's true I gotta say.
You've definitely.
- So.
- Got a point with that.
- That's one of the things I'm moving into
is sex.
- We're not.
- Coaching men in a sense
of doing big seminars
and telling them exactly how
it's supposed to be done.
- We're not swinging from the chandeliers
on a Saturday night.
- No, and we all lived, we lived,
I had lived in a ranch
with Tommy Gun, my wife
Devon Lee at the time,
two other porn stars and another guy.
And everyone was like, oh, I bet it's mad.
I'm like.
- No.
- Yeah, we go to bed at nine o'clock
after we hooked Spartacus.
And they're like, well
you don't have orgies?
I'm like, fuck no.
It's like, they just got this incredible
that we're just a crazy group of people.
We're not, we're actually
probably more normal
than the flower guy running the
flower shop down the street.
- Yeah, we go get tested every 14 days.
We're legitimately healthy.
- Very healthy.
- And we're pretty boring.
(Marcus laughs)
- Very boring they're like, come out.
I'm like, no, I'm staying
with dogs tonight.
I'm watching this really
good new show on Netflix.
- I know I've gotta go on Netflix
and we're not chilling.
(Marcus laughs)
We're eating ice cream.
- [Mark] All right you
guys thank you so much
for talking to me.
You're very welcome.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.
(Marcus laughs)
- [Mark] That was great.
I'm so glad we did it together.
- Yeah it's
- [Mark] It worked out great.
- It's a good vibe
- I could have gone on for hours.
- That's the problem I can do, days.
- Could go on for hours.
- I was like, I'm not even close,
I could go on for ever.
- [Mark] No, it was great.
It was, perfect taste of everything.
It was great.
- Yeah, I'm the more bonkers one.
He's the emotional one
- Oh yeah she's so bonkers.
- [Mark] Yeah, because it
makes the world go around.